when I write negatively of the Tories as
I said I think they may failed to make a
case for conservatism I think they've
been very schizophrenic in their
policymaking but in their defense almost
every person who was in charge during
the lockdown initially got some public
support because people rallied around
the government of the day and the
actions they took but almost all those
governments have been subsequently
kicked out I only really think of
Trudeau still Clinging On by his
fingertips so it was very difficult to
put your country through lockdown and
not pay an electoral price for it and
for the tourist it's it's just being
deferred because of the nature of the
British electoral system